The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.MIT.edu.
ALEX KELL: So, let's talk about
the historical arcs of vision
and auditory sciences.
In the mid 20th century,
auditory psychophysics was,
like, a pretty robust
and diverse field.
But currently there are
very few auditory faculty
in psychology departments,
whereas, like, vision faculty
are the cornerstone of
basically every psychology
department in the country.
In a similar vein,
automated speech recognition
is this big fruitful
field, but there's not
much kind of broader
automated sound recognition.
In contrast, computer
vision is this huge field.
So, I'm just kind of
wondering historically
and sociologically,
how did we get here?
JOSH TENENBAUM: You probably
talk about this more.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Sure, yeah.
I'm happy to tell
you my take on this.
Yes, so it's--
I think there are really
interesting case studies
in the history of science.
If you go back to the
'50s, psychoacoustics
was sort of a centerpiece
of psychology.
And if you looked around
at, like, you know,
the top universities, they
all had really good people
studying hearing.
And even some of the names that
you know, like Green and Swets,
you know, the guys that invented
signal detection theory, pretty
much.
They were psychoacousticians.
People often forget that.
But they literally
wrote the book
on signal detection theory.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
When people talked
about separating signal from the
noise, they meant actual noise.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Yeah, and there
was this famous psychoacoustics
lab at Harvard that everybody
kind of passed through.
So back then, what
constituted psychology
was something pretty different.
And it was really kind of
closely related to things
like signal detection theory.
And it was pretty low level
by the standards of today.
And what happened over time is
that hearing kind of gradually
drifted out of
psychology departments
and vision became more
and more prominent.
I think the reason for
this is that there's
one really important-- there
are several forces here,
but one really important factor
is that hearing impairment
is something that really
involves abnormal functioning
at the level of the cochlea.
So the actual signal
processing that's
being done at the
cochlea really changes
when people start to
lose their hearing.
And so there's always
been pretty strong
impetus coming, in
part, from the NIH
to try to understand
hearing impairment
and to know how to treat that.
And knowing what
happens at the front end
of the auditory
system really has been
critical to making that work.
In contrast, most
vision impairments
are optical in nature, and
you fix them with glasses.
Right?
So it's not like
studying vision is really
going to help you understand
visual impairment.
And so there was never
really that same thing.
And so, when psychology
sort of gradually
got more and more
cognitive, vision science
went along with it.
That really didn't
happen with hearing.
And I think part of that
was the clinical impetus
to try to continue to
understand the periphery.
The auditory periphery
was also just harder
to work out, because it's a
mechanical device, the cochlea.
And so you can't just
stick an electrode into it
and characterize it.
It's actually really
technically challenging
to work out what's happening.
And so that just kept people
busy for a very long time.
But as psychology was
sort of advancing,
what people in hearing
science were studying kind of
ceased to really be
what psychologists
found interesting.
And so the field kind of dropped
out of psychology departments
and moved into speech
and hearing science
departments, which
were typically
at bigger state schools.
And they never really got
on the cognitive bandwagon
in the same way that
everybody in vision did.
And then what ends up
happening in science
is there's this interesting
phenomenon where people
get trained in fields
where there are already
lots of scientists.
So if you're a grad student,
you need an advisor,
and so you often end
up working on something
that your advisor does.
And so if there's some field
that is under-represented,
it typically gets
more under-represented
as time goes on.
And so that's sort
of been the case.
You know, if you want to
study, you know, olfaction,
it's a great idea, right?
But how are you going to do it?
You've got to find
somebody to work with.
There's not many places
you can go to get trained.
And the same has been true
for hearing for a long time.
So that's my take
on that part of it.
Hynek, do you have anything
to say on the computational?
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
No, I don't know.
I'm thinking, if it
is something that also
evolved with tools available.
Because in the old days it was
easier to generate the sounds
than to generate images.
On the computer now,
it's much easier, right?
So vision and visual
research became sexier.
So I teach auditory
perception to engineers.
Also I teach a little
bit of visual perception.
And I notice that
they are much more
interested in visual perception,
especially the various effects.
And, you know, because
somehow you can see it better.
And the other thing
is, of course, funding.
I mean, you know, the hearing
research's main applications
are, as you said,
hearing prostheses.
These people don't
have much money, right?
The speech recognition, we
didn't get much of the benefits
yet from hearing
research, unfortunately.
So I wonder if this is
not also a little bit--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Can I add one?
So, maybe-- this is sort of
things you guys also gesture
towards, but I think in both--
to go back towards similarities
and not just differences.
Maybe that's what
will be my theme.
In both vision and
hearing or audition,
there's, I think, a strong
bias towards the aspects
of the problem that fit
with the rest of cognition.
And often that's mediated
by language, right?
So there's been a lot
of interest in vision
on object recognition, parts
of vision that ultimately
lead into something
like attaching
a word to a part of
an image or a scene.
And there's a lot of
other parts of vision,
like certain kinds of
scene understanding, that
have been way understudied
until recently also, right?
And it does seem like
the parts of hearing that
have been the focus are speech.
I mean, there are
lots of people in--
it's maybe not as much as
vision or object recognition,
but certainly there's a lot of
mainline cognitive psychology
who studied things like
categorization of basic speech
elements and things that
just start to bleed very
quickly into psycholinguistics.
Right?
Whereas, the parts of hearing--
at least that's been
where a lot of the focus.
But the parts of
hearing that are
more about auditory
scene analysis
in general, like sound
textures or physical events
or all the richness
of the world that we
might get through sound,
has been super understudied.
Right?
But echoing something Josh
said also or implicitly is,
just because it
might be understudied
and you need to find
an advisor doesn't
mean you shouldn't work on it.
So if you have any
interested in this,
and there's even
one person, say,
who's doing some good work on
it, you should work with them.
And it's a great opportunity.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: If I could
follow up and just say
that my sense of this is,
if you can bear with it
and figure out a way to make
it work, in the long run
it's actually a
great place to be.
It's a lot of fun to work in
an area that's not crowded.
ALEX KELL: All right.
Obviously, a large-- to kind
of transition, a large emphasis
of the summer school is
on potential symbiosis
between, like, machine and,
like, engineering and science.
And so, what have been the most
kind of fruitful interactions
between machine perception,
either vision or hearing,
over the years, and are
there any kind of lessons
that we can learn in general?
HYNEK HERMANSKY: You know, I
went a little bit backwards,
quite frankly.
I'm trained as an engineer,
and I was paid always
to build better machines.
And in the process of
building better machines,
you discover that, almost
unknowingly, we were emulating
some properties of hearing.
So then I, of course,
started to be interested,
and I wanted to get more of it.
So that's how I got into that.
But I have to admit
that in my field,
we are a little
bit looked down at.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Because
mainly not all that much,
because engineers are such that
[INAUDIBLE] that if something
works, they like it and they
don't much want to know why,
you know?
Or at least they don't
talk much about it.
So it's interesting when
I'm in engineering meetings,
they look at me as this strange
kid who works also on hearing.
And when I'm in an
environment like this,
people look at me like
a speech engineer.
But, I mean, I don't even
feel either in some ways.
But what I was wondering
when Josh was talking about,
is there anybody in this
world who works on both?
Because, you know,
that, I think,
is much more needed
than anything else.
I mean, somebody
who is interested
in both audio and
visual processing
and is capable of making this--
JOSH TENENBAUM: So not both
science and engineering,
but both vision and audition.
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
Yes, that's what
I mean, vision and audition,
with a real goal of trying
to understand both and trying
to find the similarities.
Because, personally,
I got some inspiration
from visual research, even
when I work with audio.
But I don't see
much of it anymore.
And there are some basic
questions which I would like
to ask-- and maybe I
should have sent it in--
which is like, I
don't even know which
most are the similar and
different in audio and vision.
Should I look at time?
Should I look at modulations?
Should I look at
the frequencies?
Should I look at the
spatial resolution?
And so on and so on.
So I don't know if somebody
can help me with this.
I would be very happy
to go home knowing that.
I mean, sometimes I suspect
that spatial resolution
and frequency resolution
in hearing are similar.
I'm thinking about
modulations in speech.
Josh talked a lot about it.
But there must be a
modulation in vision also.
But, of course, we never
studied much of the vision
of the moving pictures.
A lot of vision
research was fixed.
Basically, the images, right?
It was a little bit
like, in speech, we
used to study vowels.
We don't do it anymore,
because the area of speech
is something very,
very different.
The same thing is
in image processing.
I think that now it's getting
more and more, because, again,
I mean I'm going back to
availability of the machines.
You can do some work on
moving images and on video
and so on and so on.
But I don't know how much
of that is happening.
And so my question is really,
are there any similarities,
and on which level they are?
[INAUDIBLE] There is a time,
there is a spatial frequency,
there is a carrier
frequency, there
are modulations in speech.
I don't know.
I mean, I would
like to know this.
I mean, that's something
somebody can help me.
DAN YAMINS: Oh, I was--
I had-- I think those are
interesting questions,
but I actually--
I'm sure I don't have the
answers at this point.
But I was going to say
something a little--
you know, going back to the
original general question,
which is, again,
you know, this sort
of thinking about it from
a historical point of view
I think is helpful.
In the long run, I think what's
happened over the past 50
years is that biological
inspiration has been very
helpful at injecting ideas
into the engineering realm that
end up being very powerful.
Right?
I mean, I think we're seeing
kind of the arc of that right
now in a very strong way.
I mean, you know, in terms
of vision and audition,
the sort of algorithms
that are most dominant
are ones that were strongly
biologically inspired.
And there had been a
historical arc over, I think,
a period of decades, where,
first the algorithms were sort
of biologically inspired
back in the '50s and '60s,
and then they were not
biologically inspired
for a while.
Like, the biology stuff
didn't seem to be panning out.
That was sort of the dark ages
of, kind of, neural networks.
And then more recently
that has begun to change.
And, again, biologically
inspired ideas
seem to be very powerful,
for creating, you know,
algorithmic approaches.
But the arc is a
very long one, right?
And so it's not like, you
know, you discover something
in the lab and then
the next day you
would go implement
it in your algorithm
and suddenly you get 20%
improvement on some task.
All right?
That's not realistic.
OK?
But if you're willing
to have the patience
to wait for a while, and sort of
see ideas sort of slowly percol
up, I think they can
be very powerful.
Now, the other direction is
really also very interesting,
like using the algorithms to
understand neuroscience, right?
That's one where you can get
a lot of bang for your buck
quickly, right?
And it's sort of like-- it's
like that's a short-term high,
right?
Because what happens is that
you take this machine that you
didn't understand and you
apply it to this problem
that you were worried
about and that
is sort of scientifically
interesting,
and suddenly you get 20%
improvement overnight.
Right?
That is feasible in
that direction, e.g.,
taking advances from
the computational side
or on the algorithmic
side and applying them
to understanding
data in neuroscience.
That does seem to have
been borne out, but only
much more recently.
So, there wasn't much of
that at all for many decades.
But more recently that
has begun to happen.
And so I think that there
is a really interesting
open question right now as to
which thing, which direction,
is more live.
Which one is leading
at this point, I think,
is a really
interesting question.
Maybe neither of
them is leading.
But I think that certainly on
the everyday, on-the-ground
experience, as somebody who
is trying to do some of both,
it feels like the algorithms
are leading the biology.
OK?
Are leading the neuroscience,
to me, in the sense
that I feel like, in
the short run at least,
things are going to come out of
the community of people doing
algorithms development that
are going to help understand
neuroscience data
before specific things
are going to come out of the
neuroscience community that
are going to help make
better algorithms,
like in the short run.
OK?
Again, I think the long
run can be different.
And I think that's a really
deep open research program
question, is which tasks are
the ones that you should choose
such that learning about
them from a neuroscience
and psychology point of
view will help, in the five-
to 10-year run, make
better algorithms.
And if you can choose
those correctly,
I think you really have
done something valuable.
But I think that's really hard.
ALEX KELL: Yeah.
I want to push back.
I like how you said how
the engineering is really
helping the science right
now, but the science--
the seed that science
planted in the engineering.
Like, what you're talking
about is just CNNs, basically.
DAN YAMINS: Well, I
think not entirely,
because I think that
there are some ideas
in recurrent neural networks.
ALEX KELL: OK, sure.
Neural networks generally.
But the point is the ideas
that were kind of inspired
from that have been around
for decades and decades
and decades.
Are there other kinds
of key examples besides,
like, the operations that
you throw into a CNN?
The idea of convolution
and the idea
of layered computation--
these are obviously very, very
important ideas, but, like, what
are kind of other contributions
that science has given
engineering besides--?
DAN YAMINS: Well,
Green and Swets.
I mean, the thing
that he mentioned
earlier about Green and Swets
is another great example.
ALEX KELL: Yeah.
DAN YAMINS: Right.?
Psychophysics helped understand
signal detection theory.
But that's much older, but
that's a very clear example.
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
Signal detection theory
didn't come from
Green and Swets.
It came from Second World War.
DAN YAMINS: I was just
thinking of all the work--
HYNEK HERMANSKY: They did
very good work obviously,
and they indeed were
auditory people.
DAN YAMINS: And
they were actually--
they were doing a
lot of work during--
government--
JOSH MCDERMOTT: They
formalized a lot of stuff.
DAN YAMINS: Yeah,
and they did a lot--
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Yeah, I don't
want to take anything away
from them.
DAN YAMINS: But, you
know, it's interesting.
There's this great paper
that Green and Swets have
where they talked about their--
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
--was engineering.
DAN YAMINS: They talked about
their military work, right?
And they did-- they actually
worked for the military,
just, like, determining
which type of plane
was the one that they
were going to be facing.
And so, yeah, I agree
that came out of that.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: If I want
to still-- if I can still
spend a little bit of time on
engineering versus science,
we also are missing
one big thing,
which is, like, Bell Labs.
Bell Labs was the organization
which paid people for doing--
having fun.
Doing really good research.
There was no question
that, at the time,
Bell Labs were about
speech and about audio.
So there was-- a lot of
things were justified.
And even, like, Bela
Julesz and these people--
they pretended they are
working on perception
because the company
wanted to make more
money on the telephone calls.
This has gone.
Right?
Both.
Speech is gone.
Bell Labs is gone.
And maybe image is high--
image processing is in,
because the government
is interested in finding
various things from the images
and so on and so on.
So, a lot of that is funding.
Since you mentioned
neural networks,
it never stops
amazing me that people
would call artificial
neural networks anything
similar to biology.
I mean, the only thing which
I see similar there maybe
are now these layered networks
and that sort of things.
ALEX KELL: I think a lot of the
concepts were inspired by that.
I don't think it was,
like, directly-- like,
I don't think anyone takes
it as a super serious--
HYNEK HERMANSKY: But there
I still have maybe one point
to make.
Most of the ideas
which are now being
explored in neural
networks are also very old.
The only thing is that we
didn't have the hardware.
We didn't have the means,
basically, of doing so.
So technology really
supported this,
and suddenly,
yeah, it's working.
But to some people it's not even
surprising that it's working.
They say, of course.
They say, we couldn't do it.
DAN YAMINS: I think what
was surprising to them
was that it didn't
work for so long
and that people were very
disappointed and upset
about that.
And then, you know--
but I agree that basically
there's all these, like--
all the ideas are these
40-year-old or 50-year-old
ideas that people
had thought of,
typically many of them
coming out of the psychology
and neuroscience community
a long time ago but just
couldn't do anything about it.
And so that takes a long time
to bear fruit, it feels like.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: So I have more
questions rather than answers,
but to try to get back to
a question about vision
and hearing and how
we can synergistically
interact between the two.
First, I wanted to lay out a
couple of biases and almost
religious beliefs I have on the
notion that cortex is cortex,
meaning that there's
a six-layer structure,
that there are some patterns
of connectivity that have been
described both in the vision--
visual cortex as well
as auditory cortex.
They are remarkably
similar, and we
have to work with the same
type of hardware in both cases.
The type of plasticity learning
rules that have been described
are very similar in both cases.
So there's a huge
amount of similarity
to the biological level.
We use a lot of
the same vocabulary
in terms of describing problems
about invariants and so on.
And yet, at the
same time, I wanted
to raise a few
questions, particularly
to demonstrate my ignorance
in terms of the auditory world
and get answers from
these two experts here.
I cannot help but feel
that maybe there's a nasty
possibility that there are
differences between the two,
in particular the role of
timing has been somewhat
under-explored in
the visual domain.
We have done some work on
this, some other people have.
But it seems that timing plays
a much more fundamental role
in the auditory domain.
Perhaps the most extreme
example is sound localization,
where we need to
take into account
micro-second differences
in the arrival of signals
within the two ears.
I don't know anything even close
to that in the visual domain.
So that's one
example where I think
we have to say that there
is a fundamental difference.
Now thinking more about sort
of the recognition questions
that many of us are
interested in, I think,
again, timing seems to
play a fundamental role
in the auditory domain.
But I would love to hear
from these two experts here.
I easily come up with
questions about what
is an object in the
auditory domain that's
sort of defined in a
somewhat heuristic way
in the visual domain?
But we all sort of agree
on what objects are.
And I don't know
what the equivalent
is in the auditory domain.
And how much attention
should we pay to the fact
that the temporal
evolution of signals
is a fundamental aspect in
the auditory world, which
we don't really--
by and large, we don't
really think about too much
in the visual domain.
With that said, I do
hope that at the end
we will find similar fundamental
principles and algorithms,
because, as I said,
cortex is cortex.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: I
can speak to some
of those issues a little bit.
Look, I think it can be--
I mean, it's an interesting
and fun and, I think,
often useful exercise
to try to map, kind of,
concepts from one
modality onto another.
But, again, at the end of the
day, the purpose of perception
is just to figure
out what's out there
in the world, and
the information
that you get from
different modalities,
I think in some cases
it just tells you
about different kinds of things.
So sound is usually created
when something happens, right?
It's not quite-- it's not
quite the same thing as there
being an object there off
of which light reflects.
I mean, sometimes
there's, in some sense
which there's an object there.
Like a person, right?
Persons producing sound.
But, oftentimes, the
sound is produced
by an interaction between a
couple of different things.
So, really, the question
is sort of what happened,
as much as what's there.
And so, you could probably
try to find things that are
analogous to objects, but it's--
in my mind it may just not
be exactly the right question
to be asking about the sound.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Can I
just comment on that one?
Yeah, I mean, I
think, again, this
is a place where Gabriel and I
have somewhat different biases,
although, again, it's all open.
But an object to me
is not a visual thing
or an auditory thing.
An object is a
physical thing, right?
So those of you who saw Liz
Spelke's lectures on this, this
is very inspiring to me that
from very early on infants
have a concept of an
object, which is basically
a thing in the world that can
move on its own or be moved.
And the same principles apply
in vision but also haptics.
And, you know, it's
true that the main way
we perceive objects is
not through audition,
but we can certainly
perceive things about objects
from sound and often just,
echoing what Josh said,
it's the events or the
interactions between objects
that make sounds.
They make the--
physically cause sounds.
And so it's often what we're
learning from sound is--
GABRIEL KREIMAN: But
maybe if I could ask--
I don't disagree with your
definition of objects,
a la Spelke and so on.
But I guess in the
auditory domain,
if I think about
speech, you know,
are we talking about phonemes?
Are we talking about words?
I mean, if we talk about
Lady Gaga or Vivaldi,
are we talking about a
whole piece of music,
a measure, a tone, a frequency?
These are things that--
JOSH TENENBAUM:
So, structure, sort
of structure more generally.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: What's
the unit of computation
that we should think
about algorithmically?
In the same way that Dan
and us and many others
think about algorithms that
will eventually have labels
and objects, for example.
I mean, what are those
fundamental units?
And maybe the answer
is all of them, but--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Well, speech
is really interesting,
because from one
point of view, you
could think of it
as, like, what--
it's basically, like--
it's an artifact, right?
Speech is a thing that's created
through biological and cultural
evolution, manipulating a
system to kind of create
these artificial event
categories, which
we can call phonemes and
words and sentences and so on.
And, you know, surely
there was audition
before there was speech, right?
So, it seems like it's
building on a system that's
going to detect a more
basic notion of events,
physical interactions, or things
like babbling brooks or fires
or breezes.
And then animal communication.
And it hacks that, basically,
both on the production side
and the perception side.
So it's very interesting to
ask what's the structure?
What's the right way to describe
the structure in speech?
It probably seems most analogous
to something like gesture,
you know?
That's a way to hack the
visual system to create
these events visually.
Salient changes in
motion, whether for just
non-verbal communication or
something in sign language.
It's super interesting, right?
But it's, again--
I wouldn't say-- the analog--
speech isn't a set of objects.
It's a set of
structured events, which
have been created to be
perceivable by a system which
was evolutionarily
much more ancient one,
perceiving object
interactions and events.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: But I also
think it's a case that--
yeah, there's a lot of
focus on objects and vision,
but it's certainly the case
that vision is richer than just
being about objects, right?
I mean, you have--
there-- right?
I mean, there's--
I think in some sense,
the fact that you
are posing the question,
it's a reflection
of where a lot of work
has been concentrated on.
But, yeah, there's obviously--
you know, you have scenes,
there's stuff, not
just things, right?
And the same is
true in audition.
And the difference is just
that there isn't really as much
of a focus on, like, things,
only because those are not--
GABRIEL KREIMAN: Here's
the fundamental question
I'm trying to raise, as well
as the question about timing.
In the visual domain,
let's get away from objects
and think about action
recognition, for example.
And that's one domain
where you would
think that, well, you have
to start thinking about time.
It's actually extremely
challenging to come up with
good stimuli that you
cannot recognize--
where you cannot infer
actions from single frames.
And I would argue, but--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Let's
talk about events.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: But let
me say one more thing.
But please correct
me if I'm wrong.
I would argue that in
the auditory domain,
it's the opposite.
It's very hard to come up with
things that you can recognize
from a single incident.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Sure.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: You need time.
Time is inherent to the basic
definition of everything.
In the visual domain--
again, we've thought
about time and what
happens if you present
parts of objects
asynchronously, for example.
And you can disrupt object
recognition or action
recognition in that way.
But it's sort of--
again, you can do a lot without
time or without thinking
too seriously about time.
Then maybe, I don't know--
time is probably not one of
your main preoccupations,
I suspect, in the visual domain.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: I'm
not sure, because one
of the big things which
always strikes me in vision
is the saccade and
the fact that we
are moving eyes, and the
fact that it's possible even
to lose the vision,
basically, if you really
fix the things on the
retina, and so on and so on.
So vision probably
figured out different ways
of introducing time
into perception,
basically moving eyes
and maybe in sounds.
Indeed, it's happening more,
like, already out there.
But, you know, I had one
joint project actually
where we tried to work on
audio-visual recognition.
And it was the project about
recognizing unexpected things.
And that was a big pain
initially, because,
of course, vision people
thinking one way or auditory
people thinking another way.
But eventually we ended up with
the time and with the surprises
and with the unexpected
and with the priors.
And there's been a
lot of similarities
between audio and
visual world, you know?
So that's why I was maybe
saying in the beginning,
people should be
more encouraged--
now I'm looking
at the students--
to look at both.
I mean, don't just say
I'm a visual person
and I just want to know a little
bit about speech or something.
No.
I mean, these things
are very interesting.
And, of course I mean
in auditory world,
there are problems that are
very similar to visual problems.
And in the visual world there
are very similar problems
to auditory work.
You just take a speech
and take a writing, right?
And be it handwriting or
being even printed things.
I mean, these things
communicate messages,
communicate information,
in a very similar way.
So, I would just say I
got a little bit excited
because I finished my coffee.
But I would just say, let's
look for the similarities rather
than differences, and let's
be very serious about it.
Like, sort of say, oh,
finally I found something.
Like, for instance, I give
you one little example.
We had a big problem with
a perceptual constancy
when you get linear
distortions in the signal.
And I just accidentally read
some paper by David Marr
at the time, and I
didn't understand it.
I have to say I actually missed
[INAUDIBLE] a little bit.
But still, it was a
great inspiration.
And I came up with
an algorithm which
ended up to be a very good one.
Well, at the time.
I mean, I was being
beaten many times.
But, you know, let's just
look for the similarities.
That's what I'm
somehow, maybe arguing.
And that was also
my quest-- like,
I don't even know what
is similar and different
in auditory and visual signals.
So, find-- certainly maybe--
on a certain level, it
must be the same, right?
The cortex is
very, very similar.
So I believe that,
indeed, at the end
we are getting information
into our brain, which
is being used for figuring out
what's happening in the world.
And there are these big
differences at the beginning.
I mean, the senses
are so different.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Could I
nominate one sort of thing
that could be very
interesting to study that's
very basic in both vision
and audition, of where
there are some analogies?
Which is certain
kinds of basic events
that involve physical
interaction between objects.
Like, I'll try to
make one right here.
Right?
OK.
So there was a visual event,
and it has a low level
signal-- a motion signal.
There was some motion over here.
Then there was some other motion
that, in a sense, was caused.
There was some sound
that went with it.
There was the sound of the
thing sliding on the table
and then the sound
of the collision.
We have all sorts of other
things like that, Right?
Like, I can drop
this object here,
and it makes a certain sound.
And so there's very salient,
low levelly detectable,
both auditory and
visual signals that have
a common cause in the world.
One thing hitting another.
It's also the kind
of thing which--
I don't know if Liz mentioned
this in her lecture.
I mentioned this a little bit.
Even very young infants,
even two-month-olds,
understand something
about this contact
causality, that one object can
cause another object to move.
It's the sort of thing
that Shimon has shown--
Shimon Ullman has shown.
You can, in a very
basic way, use
this to pick out primitive
agents, like hands as movers.
So this is one
basic kind of event
that has interesting parallels
between vision and audition,
because there's a
basic thing happening
in the world, an exertion
of force between one
moving object when it comes
into contact with another thing.
And it creates some
simultaneously detectable
events with analogous
kinds of structure.
I think a very basic
question is, you know,
if we were to look at the
cortical representation
of a visual collision event
and the auditory side of that,
you know?
How do those work together?
What are similarities
or differences
in the representation and
computation of those kind
of very basic events?
HYNEK HERMANSKY: If I still
may, obvious thing to use
is use vision to transcribe the
human communication by speech.
If somebody wants a lot of
money from Amazon or Microsoft
or Google or government,
you know, work on that.
Because there is a clear
visual channel, which is being
used very heavily, you know?
Not only that.
I move the hands and
that sort of thing.
If somebody can help there,
I mean, that would be great.
And it's actually a relatively
very straightforward problem.
I'm not saying simple.
But it's well defined.
Because there is
a message, which
is being conveyed in a
communication by speech.
And it's being used.
I mean, lips are
definitely moving,
unless you are working
with a machine.
And hands are moving unless you
are a really calm person, which
none of us is.
And so this is one--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Just basic
speech communication.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Basic
speech communication,
as Martin [INAUDIBLE] is saying.
That would be great, really.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: I mean, it's
also worth saying, I think,
you know, most of perception
is multimodal, right?
And you can certainly
come up with these cases
where you rely on sound and
have basically no information
from vision and
vice versa, right?
But most of the
time, you get both
and you don't even really
think about the fact
that you have two modalities.
You're just, you know-- you want
to know what to grab or whether
to run or whether it's safe
to cross the street and, you
know--
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Of
course, the thing
is that you can switch off one
modality without much damage.
That's OK, because in
most of the perception
this is always the case.
You don't need all the
channels of communication.
You only need some.
But if you want to have
a perfect communication,
then you would like to use it.
But I absolutely agree that
the world is audiovisual.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
This is a comment
I was going to add to our
discussion list, which I shared
with Alex but
maybe not the rest,
is I think it's a really
interesting question, what
can be understood
about the similarities
and differences in each of
these perceptual modalities
by studying
multimodal perception?
And to put out a kind
of a bold hypothesis,
I think that, for reasons that
you guys were just saying,
because natural perception
is inherently multimodal.
And it's not just these ones.
It also involves
touch and so on.
I think that's going to
impose strong constraints
on the representations
and computations in both
how vision and audition work.
The fact that they have
to be able to interface
with a common system,
what, you know,
I would think of as a kind of
physical object events system.
But, however you
want to describe
it, the fact of multimodal
perception's pervasiveness,
the fact that you can switch
on or off sense modalities
and still do something, but
that you can really just
so fluently, naturally
bring them together
into a shared understanding
of the world, that's something
we can't ignore, I would say.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: Why are people
so sure that in everyday life,
most things are multimodal?
I'm not really sure
how to quantify that.
But is there any
quantification of this?
JOSH MCDERMOTT: No, I don't
know of a quantification.
All I mean is that, most of the
time, I mean, you're listening
and you're looking
and you're doing
everything you can to figure
out what happened, right?
I mean, it's like,
you know, you want
to know if there's
traffic coming, right?
I mean, there's noise
that the cars make.
You also look, you know?
You do both of those.
And you probably don't
even really think
about which of
them you're doing.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: No.
I'm not talking about the
most of the time part.
Yes, that's a very good example
of multimodal experience.
I can cite lots
of other examples
where I'm running and
listening to music
and they're
completely decoupled.
Or I'm working on my computer.
JOSH TENENBAUM: You
don't listen to music
when you're driving, right?
GABRIEL KREIMAN: I do, but--
GABRIEL KREIMAN: No, but no.
But, I mean, not in
the way that, like--
sure, you listen to
music, obviously.
You listen to music
when we're driving,
but we try-- it's sort of
important that it doesn't
drown out all other sounds.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: I'm just
wondering to what extent this--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Ok, fine.
ALEX KELL: And how
much of that is, like,
kind of the particular,
like, the modern-- like,
in the contemporary world you
can actually decorrelate these
things in a way that in the
natural world you can't.
Like, if you are a
monkey, these things
would probably be a lot
more correlated than you are
as a human in the 21st century.
Like, there would be a
[INAUDIBLE] physical world
causing the input to both
your modalities in a way
that you can break now, right?
Like, I don't know.
That feels--
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
You may be right.
I haven't really thought
deeply about this.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
I'm not [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH MCDERMOTT: It would
be interesting to compute
some statistics of this.
GABRIEL KREIMAN: I'm not
disputing the usefulness
of multimodal perception.
I think it's fantastic.
I'm just wondering.
I think vision can do very
well without the other auditory
world.
And vice versa.
DAN YAMINS: We could just close
our eyes right now, all of us,
and we'd have a fine
panel for a while.
JOSH TENENBAUM: But many
of the social dynamics
would be invisible, literally.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: No, I
think you'd probably
get a lot of reciprocity.
It's an open question.
JOSH TENENBAUM: You'd get
some, but, like, there's
a difference.
Have you ever listened
to a radio talk show?
Sometimes these days the shows
are broadcast on TV and also--
and it's, like, when you
watch you're like, oh my--
like, you have a
totally different view
of what's going on.
Or, like, if you're
there in the studio.
I mean, I totally agree that
these are all open questions,
and it would be nice
to actually quantify,
for example, what to me is this
often subjective experience.
Like, sometimes if the
sound is, you know--
I don't know.
You turn off the
sound on something
where you're used to
having the sound, it
changes your experience, right?
Or you turn on
the sound in a way
that you had previously
watched something, right?
Like, you could do experiments
where you show people
a movie without the sound and
then you turn on the sound.
You know, in some ways
transform what they see
and in some ways not.
So, maybe the right thing to
say is more data is needed.
DAN YAMINS: But don't you guys
think, though, that, like,
even independent of multimodal,
there's still actually
a lot of even more
basic questions
to be asked about
similarity and differences?
Like, I mean, just from a very--
from my point of view since
that's the only one I'm usually
able to take, like,
you took a bunch
of convolutional
neural networks and you
train some of them on vision
tasks and some of them
on audition tasks, right?
And you figured out
which architectures
are good for audition
tasks and which
are good for vision tasks.
See if the architectures
are the same,
and if indeed the architectures
are fairly similar,
then, like, looking
at the differences
between the features
at different levels.
I mean, I know that
that's a very narrow way
to interpret the
question, but it's one.
And there's probably
a lot that can be--
JOSH TENENBAUM: You guys
have been doing that.
What have you learned
from doing that?
ALEX KELL: We haven't
done it that exhaustively.
DAN YAMINS: We haven't
But suffice it to say
that the hints are,
I think, very interesting.
Like, you begin to
see places where
there are clear similarities and
clear differences and asking,
like, where did the
divergence occur?
Are there any underlying
principles about what layers
or what levels in the
model those divergences
start to occur?
Can you see similarities
at all layers
or do you start to
see sort of a kind
of a clear branching point?
Right?
Moreover, like what about
lower layers, right?
I mean, you start to
actually see differences
in sort of frequency content in
auditory data and differences
between that and
visual data that
seem to emerge very
naturally from the underlying
similarities.
You know, underlying differences
between the statistics.
But still, downstream
from there,
there are some deep similarities
about extraction of objects
of some kind or other.
You know, auditory
objects, potentially.
And so I think that's
a very narrow way
of posing the question.
And I don't say that everybody
should pose it that way by any
means.
But I just think that before we
get to multimodal interaction,
which is interesting,
I think there's just
this huge space of
clear, very concrete ways
to ask the question of
similarities and differences
that are--
like, almost no matter
what you'll find,
you'll find something
interesting.
JOSH TENENBAUM: You're saying
if we enlarge the discussion
from just talking
about vision audition
to other parts of
cognition, then we'll
see more of the similarities
between these sense modalities,
because they will be the
differences that stand out
in relief with respect
to the rest of cognition.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's
a valuable thing to do,
and it connects to what
these guys were saying,
which is that there's
a sense in which this--
you know, something like these
deep convolutional architecture
seem like really good ways to
do pattern recognition, right?
This is what I would see as
the common theme between where
a lot of the successes happened
in vision and in audition.
And I don't think-- and, again,
everybody here has heard me say
this a bunch of times--
I think that pattern
recognition does not
exhaust, by any
means, intelligence
or even perception.
Like, I think even within
vision and audition,
there's a lot we do that
goes beyond, at least
on the surface, you
know, pattern recognition
and classification.
It's something more like
building a generative model.
Maybe this is a good time to--
that's another theme
you wanted to bring in.
But, you know,
something about building
a rich model of the world and
its physical interactions.
And, to me, you
know, and, again,
something Dan and I have talked
a lot about it and I think
it's--
you know, you've heard
some of this from me,
and Dan has got some really
awesome work in a similar vein
of trying to understand
how, basically,
deep pattern
recognizers-- to me,
that's another way we could call
deep convolutional pattern--
or just deep invariant
pattern recognizers,
where the invariance is
over space or time windows
or whatever it is that
deep convolutional--
you know, these are
obviously important tools.
They obviously have
some connection
to not just the six
layer cortex architecture
but these multiple-- you
know, the things that goes on
in, like, the ventral
stream, for example.
I don't know, the
auditory system as well.
But it's going on from one
cortical area to a next.
A hierarchy of processing.
That seems to be a way that
cortex has been arranged
in these two sense modalities
in particular to do
a really powerful kind
of pattern recognition.
And then I think there's
the question of, OK,
how does pattern recognition fit
together with model building?
And, you know, I think in
other areas of cognition
you see a similar kind
of interchange, right?
It might be-- like, this has
come up a little bit in action
planning-- like,
model-based planning
versus more model-free
reinforcement learning.
And those are,
again, a place where
there might be two
different systems that might
interact in some kind of way.
I think pattern recognition
also is useful all over--
you know, where cognition
starts to become
different from
perception, for example.
There's so many ways, but
things like when you have a goal
and you're trying to solve
a problem, do something.
Pattern recognition is often
useful in guiding problem
solving, right?
But it's not the same
as a plan, right?
So, I don't know
if this is starting
to answer your question, but I
think this idea of intelligence
more generally as
something like--
I mean, the way Laura put it
for learning, the same idea,
she put it as, like, goal
directed or goal constrained--
how did she put it?--
problem solving or
something like that, right?
That's a good way to-- if
you need one general purpose
definition of cognition,
that's a good way to put it.
And then, on the other hand,
there's pattern recognition.
And so you could ask, well, how
does pattern recognition more
generally work and
what have we learned
about how it works in the
cortex or computationally
from studying the commonalities
between these two sense
modalities?
And then how does
pattern recognition
play into a larger
system that is basically
trying to have goals,
build models of the world,
use those goals to guide its
action plans on those models?
ALEX KELL: On the public of
convolutional neural networks
and deep learning, like,
they are reaching, like,
kind of impressive
successes and they
might eliminate some
similarities and differences
between the modalities.
But, in both cases,
the learning algorithm
is extremely non-biological.
And I was wondering
if any of you guys--
like, infants
don't need millions
of examples of label data
to learn what words are.
So I was wondering
if you guys have
any kind of thoughts on how
to make that algorithm more
biologically possible?
DAN YAMINS: I would go to
what Josh said earlier,
which is you look at
those real physically
embodied environment.
You look for those low level
cues that can be used to, like,
be a proxy for the higher
level information, right?
And then what you
really want is--
ALEX KELL: Can you be
a little more specific?
What do you mean?
DAN YAMINS: Well,
do you want to be--
JOSH TENENBAUM: I mean,
some people have heard this
from Tommy and
others here about,
like, sort of kinds of
natural supervision, right?
I mean, several people have
talked about this, right?
Is that what you're getting at?
The idea that, often,
just tracking things
as they move in
the world gives you
a lot of extra
effectively labeled data.
You're getting lots of different
views of this microphone
now, or whatever, for walking
around the stage or all
of our faces as we're rotating.
So, when you pointed to the
biological implausibility
of the standard way of
training deep networks,
I think a lot of
people are realizing--
and this was the main idea
behind Tommy's conversion
to now be a strong prophet
for people learning instead
of being a critic, right?--
was that, the issue
of needing lots of
labeled training, that's
not the biggest issue.
There's other issues,
like backpropagation
as a mechanism of actually
propagating error gradients all
the way down to a deep network.
I think that
troubles more people.
DAN YAMINS: I have quite
the opposite view on that.
JOSH TENENBAUM: OK.
DAN YAMINS: Yes.
I agree that it's true that
the specific biological
plausibility of a specific deep
learning, like backpropagation
algorithm is probably suspect.
But I suspect that
by the same token,
there are somewhat
inexact versions that
are biologically plausible
or more plausible
anyway that could
work pretty well.
I think that's less like--
let me put it this way.
I think that's a
flashy question.
I think if you actually
end up solving that
both from an algorithm
point of view
and maybe, more importantly,
seeing how that's implemented
in a kind of real
neural circumstance,
you'll win the Nobel Prize.
But, I mean, I think that--
I feel like that's something
that will happen, right?
I think that there
is a bigger question
out there, which is, you know--
I do think that from an
algorithmic point of view
which things that people
don't yet know how to do,
how to replace, like, millions
of heavily semantic training
examples with those
other things, right?
Like, the things that you just
mentioned a moment ago, like,
the extra data.
Like, it hasn't actually
been demonstrated
how to really do that.
And I feel like the details of
getting that right will tell us
a lot about the signals that
babies and others are paying
attention to in a way that's
really conceptually very
interesting and, I think, not
so obvious at this point how
that's--
I think it'll happen
too, but it will
be conceptually interesting
when it does in a way
that I think that--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Both
are pretty interesting.
DAN YAMINS: Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Some people are more
worried about one or the other.
But, yeah.
DAN YAMINS: Exactly.
And, personally, I would
say that, from an algorithm
point of view, I'm more
interested in that second one,
because I think that will be
a place where the biology will
help us teach how to
do better algorithms.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Learning
about the biological mechanism
backpropagation seems
less likely to transform
our algorithms.
Although, again, if you ask
Andrew Sax-- he's one person.
He's been here.
He's think-- that's the
question he most wants to solve,
and he's a very smart person.
And I think he has
some thoughts on that.
But I-- my sympathies
are also with you there.
I think there are other things
besides those that are both
biologically and cognitively
implausible that need work,
too, so those-- but those are
two of the main ones that--
HYNEK HERMANSKY: I think
you are touching something
very interesting, and one of
the major problems with machine
learning in general,
as I see it,
which is like use of transcribed
or untranscribed data.
And I think that this is one
direction, which actually,
specifically in the speech,
it's a big, big, big problem
because, of course,
data is expensive, so--
unless you are Google.
But even there, you will want
to have it transcribe data.
You want to know what is inside,
and clearly, this is not what--
JOSH TENENBAUM: You guys
have this thing in speech.
I think this is I'd like to
talk more about this because you
guys have this thing,
particularly at Hopkins,
in speech that you call zero
resource speech recognition.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Right, that's--
JOSH TENENBAUM: And I think
this is a version of this idea,
but it's one of the places where
studying not just neuroscience.
But cognition and what
young children do,
the ability to get so
much from so little
is a place where we
really have a lot
to learn on the engineering
side from the science.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Yes,
I mean, [INAUDIBLE]
that I could speak about it
a little bit more in depth.
But definitely, this is the
direction I'm thinking about,
which is like what do you
do if you don't know what
is in the signal, but you
know there is a structure,
and you know that there
is information you need.
And you have to start
from the very scratch,
figure out where information
is, how is it coded,
and then use it in the machine.
And I think it's
a general problem
in the same thing as in region.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Maybe-- you're asking
several different questions.
I mean, I don't know if--
have people in the
summer school talked
about these instabilities
It's an interesting question.
People are very much
divided on what they say.
And I do think that
generative models are going
to come out differently there.
But, again, I don't want to
say generative models are
better than discriminatively
trained pattern recognizers.
I think, particularly
for perception
and a lot of other areas,
what we need to understand
is how to combine
the best of both.
So in an audience where people
are just neural networks,
rah, rah, rah, rah,
rah, and that's
all there is, then I'm going to
be arguing for the other side.
But that's not that I
think they are better.
I think they have complementary
strengths and weaknesses.
This might be one.
I think pretty much any pattern
classifier, whether it's
a neural network
or something else,
will probably be susceptible
to these kind of pathologies
where you can basically hack up
a stimulus that's arbitrarily
different from an actual
member of the class that
gets classified.
Basically, if
you're trying to put
a separating surface between
two or n finite classes--
I was trying to see how to
formulate this mathematically.
I think you can basically
show that it's not
specific to neural networks.
It should be true for any
kind of discriminatively
trained pattern classifier.
I think generative
models have other sorts
of illusions and pathologies.
But they're definitely
going to be--
my sense is they're going
to be some of the ways
that any pattern
classifier is susceptible,
that generative models
won't be susceptible to.
And there will be others that
they will be susceptible to.
But it's sort of an
orthogonal issue.
But I think the illusions
that generative models are
susceptible to,
are generally going
to have, like, interesting,
rational interpretations.
It's going to tell
you something.
They're less likely to be
susceptible to just completely
bizarre pathologies that
we look at and are like,
I don't understand
why it's seeing that.
On the other hand, they're
going to have other things that
will frustrate us.
And my inference
algorithm is stuck.
I don't understand why my
Markov chain isn't converging.
If that's the only way
you're going to do inference,
you'll be very frustrated by
the dynamics of inference.
And that's where,
hopefully, some kind
of pattern recognition system
will come to the rescue.
And if we just look at
anecdotal experience,
both in speech and vision,
there are certain kinds
of cases where, like, you
know, in a passing rock,
you suddenly see a
face, or a noise.
Or in a tree people
will see Jesus's face
on arbitrary parts
of the visual world.
And also sometimes in sound.
You hear something.
So this idea of seeing signal in
noise, we know humans do that.
But, for example, there are
ways to get deep confidence
in vision to see--
you can start off with
an arbitrary texture.
Have you seen this stuff?
And massage it to look like--
like you can start off with
a texture of green bars
and make it look like
a dog to the network,
and it doesn't look
like a dog to us.
And we're never going to see
a dog in a periodic pattern
of green and polka dotted bars.
JOSH MCDERMOTT:
But the reason you
can do that is because
perfect access to the network.
Right?
And if you had perfect access
to visual stimuli [INAUDIBLE]..
JOSH TENENBAUM: Sure.
Sure.
But I'm just saying--
these don't--
well, I don't think so.
DAN YAMINS: Of
course there's going
to be visual illusions
in every case.
The question is
whether or not they're
going to make sense to humans--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Right.
And I think some of them--
ALEX KELL: --as a test of
whether or not that model--
JOSH TENENBAUM: If you
learned something from that.
DAN YAMINS: --is a real model.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Just to be clear,
the ones that the convnets
are susceptible to that say
a generative model
or a human isn't--
they're not signs that
they're fundamentally broken.
Rather they're signs of any
discriminatively trained
pattern recognizer.
I would predict, whether
it's good or bad,
it's signs of the limitations
of pattern recognition.
DAN YAMINS: Or signs of the
limitation of the type of tasks
that are being used of which
the recognition is being done.
If you replaced something like
categorization with something
like the ability to predict
geometric and physical
interactions x period
of time in the future,
maybe you'd end up with
quite different illusions.
Right?
There's something very
brittle about categorization
that could lead to, sort of
null space as being very broad.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Exactly.
That's what I mean.
By pattern recognition, I
mean pattern classification
in particular.
Not prediction but
classification.
DAN YAMINS: Right.
But I don't think it's yet known
whether the existence of these,
sort of fooling images or this
kind of weird allusions, e.g.
the models are bad
or do not pick out
the correct resolutions.
I don't know whether--
people are not totally
sure whether that's
like, the networks
need to have feedback,
and that will be what you
really need to solve it.
It's at that broad
level of mechanism.
Or is it like,
the task is wrong?
So it's sort of a
little bit less bad.
Or maybe like Josh said, it's
like the easiest thing would
be, well, actually
if you just did this
with the neural system, you'd
find exactly the same thing.
But we don't have access to
it, so we're not finding it.
Right?
And so I think it's not
totally clear where it is yet.
Right?
It's a great question, but I
feel like the answers are murky
right now.
ALEX KELL: Yeah.
OK.
On the topic of feedback, I
wanted to kind of move over--
and Gabriel talked about
feedback during his talk.
And there's really
heavy kind of feedback
in both of these
modalities, where,
like, in hearing as
Josh talked about,
it goes all the
way back to, it can
alter the mechanics
of the cochlea,
of the basilar membrane.
That's pretty shocking.
That's pretty interesting.
So what is the role--
Gabriel talked about a
couple of specific examples
where feedback would
actually be useful.
Can you say something
more broadly about,
in general when is feedback
useful across the two
modalities?
Do we think they are kind
of specific instances--
can we talk about specific
instances in each?
GABRIEL KREIMAN: Throughout
the visual system
there is feedback essentially
all over except for the retina.
Throughout the
auditory cortex, again
this feedback and recurrent
connections all over.
We've been interested in
a couple of specific apps
in situations where feedback
may be playing a role.
This includes visual search.
This includes
pattern completion,
feature-based attention.
I believe, and hopefully
Josh will expand on this
that these are problems
that at least at a very
superficial level also exist
in the auditory domain,
and where it's tempting to
think that feedback will also
play a role.
More generally, you
can mathematically
demonstrate that any
network with feedback
can be transformed into
a feed-forward network
just by decomposing
time into more layers.
So I think ultimately,
feedback in the cortex
may have a lot to do with, how
many layers can you actually
fit into a system
the size of the head
that it has to go through--
interesting places
at some point.
And there are sort of
physical limitations
to that more than fundamental
computational ones.
At the heart of this
is the question of,
how many recurrent
computations do you need?
How much feedback you actually
need, how many recurrent loops
you need.
If that involves only
two or three loops,
I think it's easy
to convert that
into a feed forward network
that will do the same job.
If that involves hundreds
of iterations and loops,
it's harder to think about
a biological system that
will accomplish that.
But at least at the
very superficial level,
I would imagine that--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Can I ask
a very focused version
of the same question,
or try to, which
is, what is the computational
role of feedback
in vision and audition?
Like when we talk
about feedback,
maybe we mean something
like top-down connections
in the brain or something
like recurrent processing.
Just from a computational
point of view of the problem
we're trying to
solve, what do we
think its roles are
in each of those?
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
So more and more,
I think that's the wrong
kind of question to ask.
If I ask you--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Why?
GABRIEL KREIMAN: What's the role
of feed-forward connections?
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Pattern recognition.
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
There is no role
of feed-forward connections.
JOSH TENENBAUM: No.
On the contrary.
Tommy has a theory of it.
You know, you have
another theory.
Something like
very quickly trying
to find invariant features--
trying to very quickly
find invariant features
of certain classes of patterns.
That's a hypothesis.
It's pretty well supported.
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
There's a lot of things
that happen with feed-forward.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: If you
want a feed so that you
can make things better
somehow, I mean, you
need a measure of
goodness first.
I mean, otherwise I
mean, how to build--
I agree with you
that you can make
a very deep structure which will
function as a feedback thing.
But always what
worries me the most,
and in general a number
of cognitive problems,
is, how do I provide my machine
with some mechanism which
tells the machine that
output is good or not?
If the output is bad, if my
image is making no sense,
there is no dog but it's a kind
of weird mix of green things
and it's telling me it's
a dog, I need feedback.
That's the point I need
the feedback, I believe.
And I need to fix things.
Josh is talking about
tuning the cochlea.
Yeah, of course that means
that sharpening the tuning
is possible.
But in communication,
I mean, if things
are noisy I go ahead
and close the door.
There's the feedback to me.
But I know, as a
human being, I know
information is not
getting through,
and I do something about it.
And this is what we--
JOSH TENENBAUM:
That's great You just
gave two good examples
of, I think, just
to generalize those,
right, or just to say them
in more general terms.
One role of feedback that
people have hypothesized
is like in the context of
something like analysis
by synthesis.
If you have a high level
model of what's going on,
and you want to see, does
that really make sense?
Does that really explain
my low level data?
Let me try it out and see that.
Another is, basically
saying, the role
of the feed-forward connections
is a kind of invariant pattern
recognizer, and tuning
those, tuning the filters,
tuning the patterns to
context or in particular
in a contextual way to
make the features more
diagnostic in this
particular context.
Those are two ideas.
And they are probably others.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Yeah, you
gave the wonderful example
with analysis by synthesis.
But even there, we
need an error measure.
And I'm not saying
that least mean
squared error between
what I generate
and what I see is the right one.
JOSH TENENBAUM: So
you think feedback
if it helps tune
the error measure.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Well, no.
It's a chicken and egg problem.
I think I need the error
measure first, before I even
start using the feedback.
Because, you know, feedback,
we can talk about it.
But if you want to
implement it, you
have to figure out, what
is the error measure
or what is the criteria?
And that I recognize my output
is bad or not good enough.
Obviously it will
a little bit bad.
Right?
I am not good enough and I
have to do something about it.
Once I know it, I know
what to do, I think.
Well maybe not me, but
my students, whatever.
This is one of the big problems
in which we are working
on actually-- figuring
out, how can I
tell that output from my
neural net or something
is good or bad?
And so far I don't
have any answer.
JOSH TENENBAUM: But I think it's
neat that those two or three
different kinds of things--
they are totally parallel
in vision and audition.
They're useful for
both, engineering-wise,
and people have long proposed
them both in psychology
and neuroscience.
GABRIEL KREIMAN:
Generally I think
there's a lot to be done
in this area, I think.
And the notion of adding--
I mean, a lot of
what's been happening
in commercial networks is
sort of tweaks and hacks
here and there.
If there are fundamental
principles that
come from studying recurrent
connections and feedback
from the auditory domain,
from the visual domain,
those are the sort of things
that, as Dan was saying,
could potentially sort of lead
to major jumps in performance
or in our conceptual
understanding of what
these networks are doing.
I think it's a very rich
area of exploration,
both in vision and
the auditory world.
ALEX KELL: And wanted to
ask Josh one more thing--
the common constraints thing.
You were kind of saying like,
it seems like there would
be common constraints
and there are probably
consequences of those.
What are some kind of
specific consequences
that you think would come out?
Like, how can we
think about this?
To the extent that there
is kind of a shared system,
what does it mean?
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Well-- so again, I
can only, as several of
the other speakers said,
only give my very, very
personal, subjectively
biased view.
But I think the brain
has a way to think
about the physical
world to represent,
to perceive the physical world.
And it's really like a
physics engine in your head.
And that the different--
it's like analysis
by synthesis that's
a familiar idea probably
best developed classically
in speech, but in a way
that's almost independent
of sense modality.
I think we have different
sensory modalities,
and they're all just
different projections
of an underlying physical
representation of the world.
I think that, whether
it's understanding
simple kinds of events as I
was trying to illustrate here,
or many other kinds of
things, I think, basically,
at some one, one of
the key outputs of all
of these different
sensory processing
pipelines has to be
a shared system that
represents the world
in three dimensions
with physical objects that
have physical reality--
properties like mass
or surface properties
that produce friction when it
comes to motion-- roughness.
Right.
There's some way to think about
the forces, whether the force
that one object
exerts on another,
or the force that an object
presents in resisting,
when I reach for it, either the
rigidity that resists my grasp
and that [INAUDIBLE] with it.
Or the weight of
the object that that
requires me to exert
some weight to do that.
So I think there
has to be a shared
representation that bridges
perception to action.
And that it's a
physical representation,
and that it has to bridge--
it's the same representations
that's going to bridge the
different sense modalities.
DAN YAMINS: Yeah, but
to make [INAUDIBLE]..
JOSH TENENBAUM: More what?
DAN YAMINS: More
brain meat-oriented,
I think that there's
a version of that
that could be a constraint
that is so strong that you have
to have a special
brain area that's
used as the
clearinghouse for doing
that common representation.
JOSH TENENBAUM: I'm
certainly not saying that.
DAN YAMINS: OK.
Right.
No, I didn't think you were.
But that would be
a concrete result.
Another concrete result
is like effectively
that the individual modality
structures are constrained
in such a way that
they have an API that
has access to information
from the other modality,
so that message passing is
efficient, among other things.
Right?
And I think that they
can talk to each other.
JOSH TENENBAUM: I think
it's often not direct.
I think some of it might be,
but a lot of it is going to be--
it's not like vision talking
to audition, but each of them
talking to physics.
DAN YAMINS: Right.
Right.
JOSH TENENBAUM: It's
very hard for a lot of--
DAN YAMINS: Right.
And that's a third--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Mid-level
vision and mid-level audition
are hard to talk to each other.
DAN YAMINS: Right.
And a third possibility is
is that it's actually not
really so much of-- it that
there's no particular brain
area, and they're not exactly
talking to each other API
directly.
It's just that there is a common
constraint in the world that
forces them to have
similar structure
or sort of aligned structure
for representing the things that
are caused by the same
underlying phenomenon.
And that's like the weakest
of the types of constraints
that you might have.
Right?
The first one is very strong.
JOSH TENENBAUM: But it's not
it's not vague or content-less.
So, Nancy Kanwisher
and Jason Fisher
have a particular hypothesis.
They've been doing some
preliminary studies
on the kind of intuitive
physics engine in the brain.
And they could point to
a network of brain areas,
some premotor, some parietal.
You know, it's possible.
Who knows.
It's very early days.
But this might be
a candidate way
into a view of
brain systems that
might be this physics engine.
DAN YAMINS: Right.
But you are--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Also
ventral stream area.
DAN YAMINS: [INAUDIBLE]
be something like,
if you optimized network's
set of parameters
to do the joint physics
prediction interaction task,
you'll get a different result
than if you sort of just
did each modality separately.
And that would be a better--
that new different thing would
be a better match to the
actual neural response patterns
in interesting--
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
I think would make really
cool thing to explore.
DAN YAMINS: And that's, I think
the concrete way with cache
out.
And that certainly
seems possible.
JOSH TENENBAUM: And
it might be, you know,
a lot of things which
are traditionally called
association cortex, right.
This is an old idea and I'm
not enough of a neuroscientist
to know, but a
cartoon history is,
there are lots of parts of the
brain that nobody could figure
what they were doing
because they didn't respond
in an obvious selective way to
one particular sense modality.
It wasn't exactly obvious
what the deficit was.
And so they can be called
the association cortex.
That connects to the study
of cross-modal association
and association to semantics,
and this idea of association.
It's this thing you say
when you don't really
know what's going on.
But it's quite possible
that big chunks
of the brain we're
calling association cortex
are actually doing
something like this.
They're this convergence
zone for a shared
physical representation
across different perceptional
modalities and bridging
to action plan.
And a big open
challenge is that we
can have what feels to
us like a deep debate
that we can think of as like the
central problem in neuroscience
of, how do we combine
whatever you want to call it--
I don't know, generative
and discriminative
or model-based analysis
by synthesis and pattern
recognition synthesis.
But actually there's
a lot of parts
of the brain that have to
do with reward and goals.
And again, I thought
Laura's talk was
a really good
illustration of this,
understanding perception
is representing
what's out there in the
world, but that's clearly got
to be influenced by your goal.
And what is certainly
a big problem
is the relation between those.
It says something that most of
us who are studying perception
don't think we need
to worry about that.
But I think we should,
particularly those of us,
again, echoing what Laura said--
if we're studying
learning, we definitely,
I think, need to think
about that more than we do.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: It may
not be exactly related
to what you are asking,
but I don't know.
I believe that we are
carrying the model
of the world in our brain,
and we are constantly
evaluating the fit of what we
expect to what we are seeing.
And as long as we are seeing
or hearing what we expect,
we don't work very
hard, basically,
because the model is there.
You know what I'm going to say.
I'm not saying anything special.
I look reasonable
and so on and so on.
And when the model of the world
is for some reason violated,
that may be one way how
to induce the feedback,
because then suddenly I
know I should do something
about my perception.
Or I may just give up and say--
or I become very,
very interested.
But I think this is a
model of the world priors
which we all carry with us.
It's extremely
important and it helps
us to move through the world.
That's my feeling.
In speech we have a somehow
interesting situation
that we can actually predict--
say we are interested in
estimating probabilities
of the speech sounds.
But we can also predict them
from the language model.
Our language model
is learned typically
very differently
from a lot of texts,
and it's a lot of things.
And so we had quite
a bit of success
in trying to determine
if the world recognizes
if it's working well or not, by
comparing what they recognize
and expect and what it sees.
And as long as these things
go together well, it's fine.
If there is a problem
between these two,
we have to start working.
JOSH TENENBAUM: I
think, you know, physics
is a source of beautiful
math and ideas.
I think it's an interesting
thing to think about,
maybe some tuning of
some low level mechanisms
and in both sensory
modalities might
be well thought of that way.
Right.
But I think it is
dangerous to apply
too much of the
physicist's approach
to the system as a whole.
This idea that we're going to
explain deep stuff about how
the brain works as some kind of
emergent phenomenon, something
that just happened to work
that way because of physics.
This is an engineered system.
Right.
Evolution engineered brains.
It's a very complicated--
I mean, we have had a version
of this discussion before.
But I think it's
something that a lot of us
here are committed to.
Maybe not all of us.
But the way I see it is, this is
a reverse engineering science.
And the brain isn't an accident.
It didn't just happen.
There were lots of forces
over many different timescales
acting to shape it to have
the function that it does.
So if it is the case that there
are some basic mechanisms,
say maybe at the synaptic
level that could be described
that way, it's not an accident.
They were [INAUDIBLE].
I would call that, you know,
biology using the physics
to solve a problem.
And again there's a long history
of connecting free energy type
approaches to various
elegant statistical inference
frameworks.
And it could be very
sensible to say, yes,
at some levels you could
describe that low level
sensory adaptation as doing that
kind of just physical resonance
process.
Or nonequilibrium stat
mech could describe that.
But the reason why
nature has basically
put that physics
interface in there
is because it's
actually a way to solve
a certain kind of adaptive
statistical inference problem.
ALEX KELL: All right.
Cool.
Let's thank our panel.
[APPLAUSE]